>> Tucker: IN 19022, TWO,
ILHAN OMAR CAME FROM A REFUGEE
CAMP IN EAST AFRICA, KENYA.
THREE YEARS LATER SHE RECEIVED
REFUGEE STATUS AND FIVE YEARS
AFTER THAT A U.S. CITIZEN.
SHE HAS BEEN ATTACKING THE
UNITED STATES AS RACIST EVER
SENSE.
ACCORDING TO OMAR BARELY A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS COUNTRY
AND TERRORIST GROUPS LIKE
AL QAEDA.
IN A INTERVIEW OMAR COMPLAINED
THERE WAS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN AMERICA AND AL QAEDA,
WATCH.
>> WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE, I TOOK
A TERRORISM CLASS.
EVERY TIME THE PROFESSOR SAID
AL QAEDA, HIS SHOULDERS WENT UP.
YOU KNOW.
YOU DON'T SAY AMERICA WITH
INSENSITIVITY.
ENGLAND WITH INTENSITY.
YOU DON'T SAY THE ARMY WITH
INTENSITY.
>> Tucker: SO SHE STILL FEELS
THIS WAY AND WE KNOW BECAUSE SHE
SPOKE TO A GROUP HOSTED BY THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CARE.
WHILE THEY ARE CONGRESSMAN
COMPLAINED AMERICA IS BIGOTED
AGAINST MUSLIMS, SECOND-CLASS
CITIZENS, SHE SAID.
NO PROOF BECAUSE OF CERTAIN
CLAIMS.
FOR GREATER FREEDOM IN AMERICA
THAN THEY DO IT ISLAMIC COUNTRY
ON THE PLANET.
THAT IS WHERE THEY MOVE HERE,
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS MORE WOULD
LIKE TO JOIN THEM AND YOU WOULD
TOO IF YOU WEAR THEM CONGRESSMAN
OMAR LIVES HERE AND IN SOMALIA,
BUT IN AMERICA BY THE WAY AN
ELECTED MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
COULD SHE DO THAT IN
SAUDI ARABIA?
NO.
IS SHE GRATEFUL?
NO, SHE NEVER STOPS COMPLAINING.
SHE MADE THIS FAMOUS REMARK
ABOUT 9/11.
>> FOUNDED AFTER 9/11, BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT SOME PEOPLE
DID SOMETHING AND THAT ALL OF US
WERE STARTING TO LOSE ACCESS TO
OUR CIVIL LIBERTIES.
>> Tucker: SOME PEOPLE DID
SOMETHING.
BUT WE ARE THE REAL VICTIMS.
OMAR UNDERSTATEMENT HAD
CRITICISM WITH IMAGES OF 9/11
ATTACKS IN CASE YOU FORGOT WHAT
PEOPLE DID.
LATE LAST WEEK THE PRESIDENT
JOINED THE CRITICISM BY TWEETING
THIS VIDEO.
>> FOUNDED AFTER 9/11 BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT SOME PEOPLE
DID SOMETHING.
>> YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
>> SOME PEOPLE DID SOMETHING.
OH, MY GOODNESS, THERE IS SMOKE
AT THE PENTAGON.
>> SOME PEOPLE DID SOMETHING?
>> Tucker: A LITTLE OVER THE
TOP?
ACMA MAY BE.
IF YOU ARE ILHAN OMAR YOU DO NOT
LIKE THAT VIDEO.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE TO BE
CRITICIZED, GOT IT BUT WOULD YOU
FEEL CRITICIZED BY THAT TWEET?
NOT UNLESS YOU BELIEVE
DISAGREEMENT IS THE SAME AS
VIOLENCE.
AND AS IT HAPPENS, DOES BELIEVE
THE DISAGREEMENT IS THE SAME AS
VIOLENCE OR CLAIMS TO BELIEVE
THAT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN PEOPLE ON
TELEVISION SAID TRUMP IS TRYING
TO HER ILL ON OMAR.
>> MANY ARE CALLING TRUMP'S
TWEET AND THAT VIDEO INCITEMENT
TO VIOLENCE AGAINST THE
CONGRESSWOMAN.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS TRYING TO
INCITE VIOLENCE.
>> THIS IS ALL JUST INCITEMENT
TO VIOLENCE.
>> THIS IS INCITEMENT TO
VIOLENCE.
THE GOAL IS INCITING VIOLENCE.
WE ARE GETTING INCITEMENT OF
VIOLENCE.
NO QUESTION, IS HE INCITING
VIOLENCE TOWARDS MUSLIMS?
NOT ONLY ILHAN OMAR BUT MUSLIMS
IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: CORY BOOKER WOULD
SAY LITERALLY ANYTHING WENT
FURTHER OF COURSE, THE SIGNATURE
MOVE WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE IS
SAYING SOMETHING RIDICULOUS,
BOOKER WILL TRIPLE DOWN ON
INSANITY TO BE COMPLETELY
SINCERE ABOUT IT.
IN THIS CASE, BOOKER HAPPY TO
BLAME TRUMP FOR ACTUAL TERRORIST
ATTACKS.
>> SINCE 9/11, WE HAVE HAD
TERRORIST ATTACKS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
MAJORITY RIGHT WING EXTREMIST
AND THE MAJORITY OF THOSE WHITE
SUPREMACIST ATTACKS FROM
SYNAGOGUE AND PITTSBURGH TO A
CHURCH IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
AND THESE ARE WHITE SUPREMACIST
GROUPS THAT USE LANGUAGE AS WE
SAW AS FAR AWAY AS NEW ZEALAND.
USE THE PRESIDENT'S LANGUAGE AS
ALMOST THE LICENSE FOR THE
ATTACK.
>> Tucker: I SWEAR IN 20
YEARS, EVERY FIFTH-GRADER WILL
BELIEVE 9/11 WAS COMMITTED BY
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
TOTALLY TRUE.
YOU WATCH AND HEARD IT HERE
FIRST.
THEY ARE THE REAL THREAT.
AND THAT IS WHAT BOOKER IS
SATING.
TO PROVE IT, DEMAGOGUES FROM THE
LEFT FOREVER TELLING US WHAT THE
ACADEMIC OF HATE CRIMES IN THE
COUNTRY BUT THEY ARE LYING.
THERE IS NO EPIDEMIC OF HATE
CRIMES, CALIFORNIA THE BIGGEST
DATE AND THE MOST LIBERAL STATE
AND HERE ARE THE NUMBERS 2017
CALIFORNIA CONVICTED 65 PEOPLE
OF HATE CRIMES.
65 OUT OF 40000000 PEOPLE.
BY THE WAY PURE HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA AND 2017 UNDER TRUMP
THEN 1986 UNDER THE BILL CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT EPIDEMIC IS FAKE,
PROPAGANDA AND THEY ARE TRYING
TO CONTROL YOU WITH FEAR.
YOUR OPINIONS ARE VIOLENT, THEY
SAY, YOUR OPINIONS ARE VIOLENT,
DISAGREEING WITH ME AS THOUGH
SOLD YOU MUST OBEY.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
YOU.
YOU CAN SEE WHY.
THIS IS WHERE WE COME INTO IT.
IF WE GO ALONG WITH THIS AND GO
TO THESE DEMANDS IT IS OVER.
IF WE LET THEM DEFINE SPEECH AS
VIOLENCE, IT HAS NO MEANING.
THEY CAN TELL YOU WHAT TO SAY
AND WHEN TO SAY IT.
THEY CAN USE ANY FORCE NECESSARY
TO MAKE YOU BE QUIET.
JUST AS YOU WOULD DO WHENEVER
YOU -- WHATEVER YOU NEEDED TO DO
AND WHATEVER FORCE TO STOP THE
TERRORIST ATTACK.